Si tu pouvais emmener un gars sur une île
avec toi et que tu savais que tu serais en sécurité
parce qu'il était le meilleur homme, ça
te rendrait heureux si c'était entre moi et
ton père, qui emmènerais-tu mais oui,
je pense que tu es  Je me trompe à ce sujet,
ce qui se passe est mon frère,
donc c'est le monocaméral, comprenez
quelle partie de vous n'était pas venue, je ne peux pas être
le gardien, et bien, votre frère a pourvu
à l'entretien de votre neveu, je pense que l'
idée était que vous déménageriez,
déménageriez - eh bien, si  He AG, j'avais l'
impression que tu avais passé beaucoup de
temps ici, bien ouais, je ne suis qu'un remplaçant, je veux
dire, personne ne pouvait apprécier ce que
tu as vécu et si tu
sens vraiment que tu ne peux pas prendre ça sur moi, c'est
ton  juste
là où nous allons à l'orphelinat, tais-toi,
la voiture de Kim ne peut pas obéir à tes ordres tant que
tu n'as pas déverrouillé la porte. Et
si tu décidais que tu peux toujours rester
avec nous s'il veut venir le week-end,
tu veux être son tuteur et bien, il le
fait.  pas vraiment mon Dieu, il a déjà une
maison, nous allons essayer de desserrer les horaires à ce
stade, bonjour bonjour Lee, je veux juste
appeler et dire que je suis désolé,
comment va Patrick - il ne s'ouvre pas vraiment
avec moi, tu as en fait couché avec
eux  les filles sont
strictement des affaires de sous-sol, cela veut
dire que je travaille sur
tu ne veux pas être mon dieu ici ça
me va là-bas c'est juste la
logistique tous mes amis sont ici J'ai
deux copines et je suis dans un groupe
toi'  tu es concierge et Quincy, qu'est-ce que
tu fous de l'endroit où tu vis
[Musique]
Je t'ai dit beaucoup de choses terribles,
mon cœur a été brisé, mon nez est
cassé aussi non, tu ne comprends pas, il n'y a
rien d'aussi vrai que
toi
[Musique  ] il y a
quelque chose qui ne va pas chez moi, je ne me
souviens pas de tes amis, que veux-tu faire de
mon corps, je reste assis là jusqu'à ce que tu te calmes,
d'accord, je me calme, s'il te
plaît, va-t'en, tu sais,
viens vers
toi.